da ich für mein letztes Video in Bangkok
Thailand gelandet bin musste ich von
dort aus schauen wohin meine weitere
Reise führen soll im Golf von Thailand
gibt es viele Inseln die definitiv einen
Besuch wert sind also war meine
Entscheidung schnell getroffen von der
Großstadt auf die Insel und ich habe
mich alleine auf den Weg gemacht und
damit schönen guten Morgen aus Bangkok
Leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut ich bin gerade aufgestanden wir
haben 6:30 Uhr also ziemlich früh aber
hier ist natürlich trotzdem schon die
rigorosa Berufsverkehr wobei man sagen
muss hier ist rund um die Uhr Verkehr
ich habe hier ein Bangkok jetzt auf
jeden Fall zwei Tage verbracht und heute
fliegen wir woanders hin ich habe mich
ein bisschen umgeschaut und gar nicht
mal so weit von mir also ich fliege
glaube ich so ungefähr eineinhalb
Stunden gibt es einige verdammt coole
Inseln aktuell sehr bekannt geworden
durch einiges Skandal und ist auch
scheißegal nein die Insel kennt man
glaube ich sowieso Ko Samui da fliege
ich jetzt nämlich hin da gibt's ein
Flughafen und von da aus kann man noch
zu anderen Inseln fahren und ich dachte
mir das muss ich auf jeden Fall noch
abchecken wenn ich schon mal hier bin
bevor ich wieder nach Deutschland Pflege
weil ich bin jetzt ziemlich weit weg von
zu Hause mal schauen wie lange ich dann
noch bleibe ich habe noch keinen
Rückflug ich denke das ist auf jeden
Fall noch eine coole Zeit wird und mal
sehen vielleicht will ich von dort aus
dann irgendwie auch noch woanders hin
zum Flughafen ich muss auschecken und
bis gleich
okay Leute wir sind auf jeden Fall jetzt
gleich am Flughafen angekommen ich will
doch nicht so viel sagen aber ich glaube
dass ich wieder abgezogen werde gerade
weil auf dem Hinweg hat es nur 220
gekostet und jetzt gerade meinte
irgendwie kostet 500 weil er noch
irgendein Highway bezahlen muss aber bis
jetzt hat er noch gar nichts bezahlt der
Verkehr morgen sind Bangkok ist auch
wirklich Geist gegangen also ich hätte
fast gar kein Taxi bekommen weil die
alle im Stau stehen das wird jetzt echt
ein bisschen knapp den Flug zu erwischen
aber ich denke dass ich hinbekommen
werde der Flughafen Bank ist ja auch
riesig aber wir schauen angekommen
wieder am Flughafen ich wurde doch nicht
abgezogen er meint irgendwie nicht
gefunden oder so ich habe es auch nicht
ganz gecheckt aber ich habe wieder nur
das bezahlt vom Hinweg also alles gut
bis jetzt bin ich echt zufrieden hier
die Leute sind alle super nett und ich
wurde noch nicht abgezogen ich habe es
auf jeden Fall gleich gefunden Airline
Lounges das klingt schon mal gut da kann
ich überall rein danke ich habe noch gar
nicht gefrühstückt heute und ich war
auch noch gar nicht mehr im Security
Check gefällt mir gerade ein hä das
müsste eigentlich noch kommen
ich muss sagen super nice natürlich sehr
asiatisch angehaucht aber hier gibt's
irgendwie
und irgendwann Sandwich aber das gibt's
eigentlich fast überall auch in Europa
oh nein
man kann sich hier sogar in dieser
Lounge massieren lassen guck mal warte
ich will
die einen da wir gerade einfach massiert
also es gibt echt so viele Sachen die
hier komplett anders sind in jeglicher
Hinsicht aber das ist ja nicht schlecht
also die Lounge war echt super nice kann
ich empfehlen wenn ihr mal hier seid
checkt die ab und wir fliegen jetzt los
da ich auf dem Hinflug in Frankfurt am
Flughafen ziemlich lange warten musste
habe ich dort schon den sponsert das
heutigen Videos vorgestellt das ist yes
und das Springen wir jetzt mal kurz hin
eine Sache die ich noch kurz loswerden
wollte und zwar gibt's natürlich heute
auch wieder ein Sponsor fürs Video geht
aber ganz schnell und es wirklich
hilfreich und zwar wird das Video
unterstützt von Xbox ICE ich habe die
Webseite gerade auf meinem Desktop auf
gibt's aber auch als App kurz
zusammengefasst ihr könnt über Apps das
Ice an forschungsumfang teilnehmen
dadurch erhaltet ihr einen Punkte die in
Amazon Gutscheine Zalando Gutscheine und
noch jede Menge andere coole Premium
umtauschen können die Anmeldung gefällt
einfach und das gute ist ihr könnt dann
auch an forschungsumfang teilnehmen die
hat auch eure eigenen Interessen
abzielen also ein cooler zeitvertreibt
mit dem man so gesehen auch noch easy
Gutscheine generieren kann bzw Geld
verdienen kann erster Link in der
Videobeschreibung und wir machen jetzt
weiter und ja ich hoffe jetzt gleich
hier bei Boarding also eine Sache die
man hier wirklich loben muss neben
diesem wundervollen Saugroboter da ach
nee ich glaube der wischt oder ah das
hier sogar ein Gesicht drauf also hier
am Flughafen funktioniert echt alles 1A
das sieht doch einfach daran weil
überall super viele Leute arbeiten also
hier beim Security Check Arbeiten
gefühlt fünf Mal mehr als in Deutschland
beim Security Check liegt natürlich
sicherlich auch in den Löwen aber
wirklich sehr sehr entspanntes Reisen
hier dann ging es also los hier kann man
noch mal die Skyline von Bangkok sehen
eine riesige Stadt ich fliege nach Koh
Samui an Bord gab es auch jede Menge zu
essen das ist ganz interessant man
bekommt hier in jeder Airline eigentlich
zu essen wir sind dann über Koh Phangan
geflogen und dann hier gelandet in Koh
Samui wirklich schon extrem nices
hellblaues Wasser und ja ich habe mich
super gefreut ausgestiegen und die Hitze
kamen einem entgegen aber das war ich ja
auch eigentlich schon gewohnt und der
Flughafen ist ein bisschen anders du
wirst hier mit so kleinen offenen Bussen
abgeholt wirklich sehr sehr entspannt
und ja ich freue mich
[Musik]
okay ich bin da das ist echt ein sehr
verrückter Flughafen eigentlich nichts
mehr aus wie so ein Zoo weil hier ist
alles so offen aber es ist einfach im
Flughafen und das Klima hier ich feiert
also wirklich richtig geil muss ich
eigentlich mal gucken wie ich hier zu
meinem Apartment komme
klimaanlage
ich spreche Deutsch ja jetzt
heute kurz first reaction ich bin jetzt
hier bei mir im Apartment angekommen ich
erzähle euch gleich noch mehr dazu meine
Kamera liegt nur noch hinten im Raum
weil ich das da gerade verstaut habe es
ist einfach so geistig krank schaut euch
das mal also ich habe glaube ich noch
nie sowas heftiges gesehen in meinem
Leben Alter
ich bin hier so reingegangen hast du
nach vorne geguckt und dachte mir ich
denn hier gelandet ich glaube hier
bleibe ich jetzt erstmal ein bisschen
ich bin wirklich absolut im Paradies
angekommen das ist so unfassbar krass
hier für mich auch eine absolut neue
Erfahrung weil ich war noch nie so weit
weg von zu Hause an so einem tropischen
Ort und auch meine Unterkunft hier ist
wirklich geil ich zeig's euch mal eben
hier direkt vor mir haben wir so ein
Pool und da vorne ist auch schon das
Meer leider ist es gerade ein bisschen
am regnen und es ist wirklich so wie es
auf tiktok oder überall keine Ahnung
eigentlich so wie man sich das vorstellt
Bett
ja gut eigentlich gibt es auch gar nicht
so viel zu zeigen hier ist das
Badezimmer Dusche Klo und ja aber ich
glaube ihr wisst was ich meine es ist
einfach so dieses gesamt package hier
hier kann man sich richtig entspannt ein
abchillen ich war gerade auch schon eine
mehr aber ich zeige euch das mal wenn
das Wetter ein bisschen besser ist ich
muss jetzt nämlich erstmal Arbeiten gibt
ein paar Termine die ich erledigen muss
aber für mich gar nicht beschweren okay
mittlerweile haben wir den ersten Namen
ich habe gerade zu Abend gegessen jetzt
hier am Strand entlang weil da hinten
ist die Hauptstadt von Koh Samui ich
habe gerade schon wieder den Namen
vergessen auf jeden Fall soll da mal
einiges los sein und ich dachte mir das
muss ich mir auf jeden Fall direkt mal
anschauen und dann gehen wir weiterhin
ich habe bei the way auch die Unterkunft
direkt noch um 3 Tage verlängert also
eigentlich hatte ich nur für zwei Nächte
gebucht aber ich bin so entspannt dass
ich da ein bisschen länger bleiben
möchte also hier ist auf jeden Fall
schon mal DJ JJ
okay Leute ich bin auf jeden Fall jetzt
in irgendwelche Straße
abgeht ich werde auch die ganze Zeit
angelabt Happy Hours hier überall das
ist schon gut gesagt ich muss unbedingt
die Green Mango Bar gehen da geht's ab
ja mann Ich bin zwar der einzige aber es
geht nicht ab
[Musik]
Leute was geht neuer Tag gestern Abend
war auf jeden Fall ziemlich cool ich war
glaube ich so um 2 Uhr zu Hause habe
heute ein bisschen länger geschlafen ich
war schon frühstücken eben und ein
bisschen am Strand wir gehen jetzt kurz
hier vorne noch was essen und dann gehe
ich zum Friseur und einmal einkaufen und
dann erzähle ich euch auch mal wie die
nächsten Tage so geplant sind ich habe
hier nämlich jetzt noch drei Tage
verlängert ich will sie nämlich super
angenehm und natürlich auch echt schön
mit dem Strand und so bezahlen tue ich
hier aktuell aber sogar 90 € die Nacht
was ziemlich teuer ist für die Insel
also es geht auf jeden Fall noch
deutlich günstiger aber so um
reinzukommen ich habe hier keinen Stress
kriegt die ganze Zeit essen kann Essen
bestellen finde ich in Ordnung aber
Samstag also dann sind die Tage hier
vorbei werde ich noch auf eine andere
Insel fahren und zwar nach Koh Phangan
nämlich euch natürlich mit weil ich
denke auch da wird noch einiges
passieren und das Gute ich habe einen
Kollegen der ist gerade noch auf Bali
der kommt mich vielleicht besuchen das
wäre ganz nice weil dann bin ich nicht
immer alleine viele von euch fragen mich
auch immer auf insta hä warum reichst du
die ganze Zeit alleine wollte mir gerne
auf insta da heißt die Alex hier dann
kriegt ihr alles mit ist das nicht
langweilig ja es ist oft langweilig aber
es passiert auch super viel und deswegen
ich finde es nicht so schlimm also
natürlich fühlt man sich manchmal einsam
aber ist schon okay
hier ist auf jeden Fall das Restaurant
und wenn man hier runter schaut Alter es
ist so krass ne von das Meer ist auch so
warm schaut euch das mal an
also ich kann jedem nur empfehlen wenn
ihr mal Zeit habt und Bock habt und
lange Urlaub habt und es sich lohnt so
weit weg zu fliegen fliegt mal nach
Bangkok und danach Koh Samui geil für
mich gibt's hier auf jeden Fall erstmal
so eine Art Frühlingsrollen aber super
lecker bis jetzt auf jeden Fall mein
Lieblingsessen hier das hier ist
übrigens die Straße vor meinem Hotel ach
hier ist der Linksverkehr ups ich gehe
jetzt zum Friseur muss allerdings erst
mal Geld abheben
da vorne läuft einfach capital bra hä
und hier sind ganz viele taubsis Alter
was machen die da na super
Geld habe ich auf jeden Fall jetzt
abgehoben man muss sagen bei google
steht vieles aber es gibt nicht alles
was da steht deswegen laufe ich jetzt
nicht zum nächsten Friseursalon der ist
ein Kilometer entfernt und ja mal gucken
ob ich da bin ich werde
[Musik]
sorry
okay Haare sind wieder fresh das war auf
jeden Fall ein korrekter Friseur der hat
sich auch echt Mühe gegeben und hier
sind überall so Boxkämpfe und die machen
die ganze Zeit Werbung dafür man hört
das im Hintergrund da fährt immer so ein
Auto rum also das ist hier auf jeden
Fall Boxen wahrscheinlich ziemlich
angesagt so Leute was geht vielleicht
noch leicht an meiner Stimme ich war
krank ey mir geht's echt nicht gut ich
habe mich voll erkältet auch das Klima
hier und so mein ganzer Kreislauf war
voll down ich habe jetzt drei Tage gar
nichts gemacht ich bin echt krank
geworden von der Klimaanlage hier glaube
ich hatte erst die Seite Schmerzen jetzt
habe ich noch Schnupfen und ja generell
meinen Kreislauf ist ziemlich am Arsch
das liegt glaube ich auch an den warmen
Temperaturen hier also sich so entspannt
zu erholen ist ja gar nicht mal so
einfach ist halt mega [__] weil ich bin
hier schließlich auch nicht so ewig ich
habe die letzten drei Tage nur hier in
meinem Zimmer gechillt und ein bisschen
weniger spazieren gegangen ich hoffe es
wird
wirklich noch besser naja aber ich bin
eigentlich wieder fit nur noch bisschen
Stimme belegt mein Kollege kommt jetzt
gleich endlich an dann bin ich nicht
mehr alleine ich war jetzt über eine
Woche ganz alleine und morgen checken
wir hier beim Hotel auch aus ich habe
mir noch meine Sachen waschen lassen das
kam einfach in so ein Paket hier wieder
rein finde ich voll verrückt okay Leute
für mich ging es mittlerweile weiter ich
bin auch eigentlich fast wieder fit mein
Kollege ist jetzt auch da den könnt ihr
da im Hintergrund sehen dann stelle ich
euch bei Gelegenheit noch mal vor auf
jeden Fall haben wir uns jetzt gedacht
wir müssen mal irgendwohin wo auch mehr
Leute in unserem Alter sind und hier
gibt es so ein Social Teil nennt sich
das das ist eigentlich wie ein Hostel
mit Party und so ich zeige euch das mal
kurz das hier ist unser Balkon
und so sieht das aus man muss sagen es
sieht wirklich krass aus das Problem ist
nur wir sind fast die einzigen hier so
sieht das übrigens hier unten aus bei
uns im Hostel alles eigentlich ganz
schlimme schon schön eingerichtet hier
ist so eine Bar aber irgendwie ist halt
niemand da und die Leute die jetzt hier
sind die spielen da vorne gerade
gegessen Challenge wir haben übrigens
mittlerweile auch noch einen Roller auf
Koh Samui geholt einfach damit man mehr
sehen kann eigentlich ist es ja auch
total üblich ohne Helm zu fahren aber
wir fahren natürlich mit so rum ach so
und was hier auch zu einem Tagesroutine
gehört einmal Thaimassage wir machen
meisten Fußmassage kostet umgerechnet
ungefähr 8 bis 10 € und es super
entspannt gestern Abend waren wir auf
jeden Fall noch unterwegs haben einen
ziemlich großen Ausflug gemacht es war
nur noch zwei andere deutsche dabei den
einen kann ich von RTL damals als bei
dieser Fernsehsendung die retourenprofis
mitgemacht hat das war ganz lustig er
hat ja auch ein Haus und wohnt hier
quasi so als Zweitwohnsitz da waren wir
bei so einem Boxkampf wo auch einfach
Kinder tanzen und für uns war es erstmal
oder ich war so ein bisschen geschockt
aber hier ist dieses Teil boxing halt
völlig normal
[Applaus]
und ja deswegen will ich das jetzt gar
nicht so krass kritisieren aber es sah
schon echt crazy aus ansonsten schauen
wir mal was heute noch so geht weil
morgen geht's für uns dann glaube ich
auf eine andere Insel und ich muss auch
noch ein paar Sachen zu Thailand
erzählen weil auf der einen Seite ist
wirklich richtig geil und ich fühle mich
hier sehr wohl und das ist eine richtig
coole Zeit auf der anderen Seite gibt es
natürlich auch ein paar negative Aspekte
aber das erzähle ich euch dann mal am
Ende so Leute was geht wir sind jetzt
mittlerweile noch auf eine andere Insel
gefahren dazu werdet ihr aber dann denke
ich im nächsten Video noch was erfahren
ich wollte ja noch ein abschließendes
Fazit geben ich bin jetzt 10 Tage 11
Tage schon hier erstmal muss man sagen
Thailand ist wirklich ein sehr sehr
schönes Land und vor allem diese Inseln
hier sind absolut heftig also ich kann
jedem nur empfehlen hier mal hinzufahren
und neben diesen ganzen positiven
Eindrücken die ich jetzt sammeln konnte
super viele freundliche Menschen tolle
Strände tolles vielseitiges Essen gibt's
natürlich auch ein paar negative Sachen
und das erste was man ganz klar sagen
muss was extrem nervt sobald du halt
europäisch aussieht sieht jeder
Einheimische in dir eigentlich nur eine
Gelddruckmaschine und versucht Dich auf
irgendw welche Art und Weisen irgendwie
zu scammen also man muss hier echt
unfassbar aufpassen Tipp von mir
vertraut also es klingt hart aber es ist
halt einfach so vertraut nie auf das was
einheimische euch sagen wo man irgendwie
was gut buchen kann oder sonst was weil
du wirst in 80 oder 90% der Fällen
einfach nur abgezogen dann wird überall
angelabert ob man was kaufen will in
meinem Ohr da piept schon wieder wenn
ich höre Meister hat an jeder Ecke wird
hinterher gerufen und so und das ist
echt super nervig wir haben uns hier
dieses Sat.1 Format Achtung Abzocker
angeschaut die Thailand Edition und es
ist wirklich so es ist ultra hart was da
passiert aber es ist halt einfach so was
man auch erwähnen muss in Sachen so
Tierschutz also das ist echt ein
manchmal wirklich traurig beispielsweise
wir waren in unserem Einkaufszentrum und
da kannst du einfach Hunde Hamster
Katzen kaufen die in so kleinen Käfigen
eingesperrt sind und die Töne den ganzen
Tag pissen da runter und so also und es
gibt halt auch so viel merkte wo es noch
viel schlimmer zugeht wo man aber auch
wohl nicht filmen darf wenn man da als
Tourist rum läuft und was einem auch
noch auffällt so Kinderarbeit in
Anführungsstrichen klar wir haben diesen
Boxkampf gesehen aber es arbeiten echt
an vielen Stellen z.B am Eingang bei
einer Kasse oder Arbeiten einfach Kinder
und manchmal ist auch so wenn man sich
so ein Tuk Tuk mietet da sitzt vorne die
ganze Familie drin also das ist quasi so
ein
Familienbetrieb also die Kinder sitzen
vorne am Handy der Papa fährt und die
Mutter verhandelt die Geschäfte weil das
ist hier halt so ein denken dass man
einfach auf diese Turtok steigen kann
und dann rumfährt so crazy hier hast du
gesehen die beiden Kinder sind beide am
Handy spielen und der Vater fährt jetzt
hier andere Welt halt einfach also das
waren so die Haupt negativen Aspekte die
mir so aufgefallen sind ganz wichtig
lasst euch hier nicht abziehen bucht am
besten alles im Internet dann seid ihr
immer auf der sicheren Seite und am
günstigsten ansonsten gefällt mir super
gut mal schauen was die nächsten Tage
noch so mit sich bringen vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen und ja wir sehen uns schon ganz
wieder haut rein ciao